bonsoir gilles sacaze merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france les
européens qui disent avoir besoin d'une
réponse coordonnée et rapide c'est ce
qu'a déclaré emmanuel macron mentionnant
le développement de bases de données
commune des échanges d'informations le
renforcement des politiques pénales
alors tout cela a l'air bien au général
des déclarations de bons sentiments on
se demande aujourd'hui ça n'a pas été
fait déjà avant quand même tout ça si la
coopération si vous voulez entre les
différents pays européens existent en
matière de renseignement et même en
matière de police plus opérationnelles
bien sûr qu'elle existe qu'elle soit pas
homogène entre les différents membres de
l'union européenne c'est certain qu'ils
aient des quais de grosse voix je dirais
de d'amélioration pour homogénéiser tout
ça est amené tout le monde sur des modes
opératoires et des des politiques
communes bien sûr qu'il ya un chantier
qu'il faut que la réponse elle soit
comme une commune coordonnée et rapide
si ces jalons sont tenus je dirais que
c'est effectivement bien mais on est on
est habitué du télé et à des discours
d'intention qui sont rarement suivies
d'effets alors c'est vrai que
l'actualité un peu contraint tout le
monde les peuples aujourd'hui réclament
de passer du discours à l'action
il semblerait que ceux ci étaient
entendus par pas par nos dirigeants
européens mais pour l'instant on est on
est dans l'intention donc il faudra voir
les semaines à venir
c'est bien le problème gilles sacaze
c'était ma première question n'est dans
l'intention non phase où on se souvient
parfaitement de ses discours ont
lendemain des attaques terribles qui
avait frappé la france ont en 2015 on
parlait déjà ce fameux pnr le passenger
name code
apparemment c'est un dispositif qui a
été mis en place mais pas achevé c'est
vrai qu'on peut se poser la question
décemment pourquoi est ce si compliqué
de se mettre d'accord en europe il ya eu
çà vous avez raison il ya eu également
affronter que je veux dire qui est un
immense show
et chez je dirais je suis un peu dur
dans peut-être dans mon jugement mais
aujourd'hui on dépense de l'argent pour
frontex et puis on finance également des
associations qui travaillent à des toits
a contourné frontex donc il ya ça ça
manque complètement de cohérence on se
souvient aussi de la période si vous
voulez où on a cloué au pilori la
pologne la hongrie l'autriche parce
qu'on trouvait qu'ils avaient une
politique de contrôle de l'immigration
qui correspondait pas aux normes
européennes si aujourd'hui on se
rapproche un petit politique là pour
pourra enfin protéger nos frontières
le président l'a dit encore une fois le
discours était parfait quand le
président nous a dit aujourd'hui que
schengen c'était l'abandon en gros pour
faire rapide mais l'abandon de nous de
nos frontières nationales au profit de
frontière en plein et de contrôle sur
nos frontières européennes et que et que
cette promesse n'a même pas été tenus et
que aujourd'hui on remettait en question
schengen alléluia jusqu'à présent tous
ceux qui qui remettait en question qui
avait le malheur de remettre en question
le schengen et étaient considérés comme
des réactionnaires insupportable et
menacé même d'exclusion de l'union
européenne il faut s'en souvenir
ça veut dire pas soudainement devient
souverainistes à deux ans de l'élection
présidentielle on c'est une nécessité il
ya selon vous une vraie intention une
vraie volonté là dedans il ya une vraie
on peut pas faire de procès d'intention
un cidre et connaît on a été tellement
déçus par des discours un petit peu
guerrier est suivi de rien du tout que
on est en droit aujourd'hui il est
parfaitement légitime de se poser la
question mais je crois qu'il ya une
exigence aujourd'hui on voit la classe
politique française par exemple ces
postures là il était plutôt à droite de
l'échiquier politique en france
je les postures de contrôle de
l'immigration de contrôle aujourd'hui le
lien par exemple
l'immigration et le terrorisme effet sur
les plateaux télé papa par toute la
classe politique quasi toute la classe
politique j'écoutais julien dray pour ne
pas le nommer
la semaine dernière qui faisait ce lien
sans aucun complexe si vous voulez ça
c'est une vraie évolution et je dirais
que si en france en tout cas après je
sais pas si on sera suivie au lieu de
rentrer mais on a on ad on a des alliés
c'est encore une fois les pays qu'on a
critiqués pour avoir ces postures là il
ya quelque temps si aujourd'hui on fait
au moins quinze communes avec un certain
nombre de pays européens
peut-être que les choses peuvent bouger
en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est
qu'à une vraie exigence aujourd'hui des
peuples et pas qu'en france c'est vrai
en italie c'est vrai en espagne céderait
en allemagne il ya un décalage si vous
voulez entre la posture de nos
dirigeants et les exigences et les
attentes des peuples et que ce qui est
en jeu finalement c'est c'est la
continuité de l'europe
si on construira pas une europe pas sur
le vieux continent on construira une
europe contre les peuples
on peut faire illusion quelques temps
mais je pense que la sanction risque
d'être brutal on l'a vu avec le break
site devrait exciter on l'a on n'a
jamais été au fond de l'analyse à savoir
pourquoi les anglais étaient vraiment
parce que ça c'était des sujets tabous
mais on pourrait un jour il faudra bien
faire de cette analyse là et les anglais
sont revenus à une fois à leur
souveraineté tout simplement parce que
c'est un peuple un grand peuple les
anglais souverain et insulaire depuis
toute son histoire et ils sont revenus
aux fondamentaux et le aujourd'hui c'est
le l'enjeu pour l'europe c'est ça c'est
de faire converger de d'amener les
peuples avec eux autre sujet qui est
abordé emmanuel macron la lutte contre
la haine en ligne c'est un sujet qui
regroupe beaucoup de choses pas
seulement le terrorisme parce que c'est
prendre le problème du bon goût c'est
une des composantes je dirais mais moi
ce que je crains si vous voulez c'est
que c'est ce qu'on vit depuis
encore une fois le problème du délit
sionisme
radicale de l'islam radical et de
l'islamisme en france et même du dialyse
millet révélé depuis 25 ans depuis
rallié quelqu'un moi je chaque fois je
rappelle ça parce que je pense que c'est
important ça nous ça nous empêche de
nous des douanes est de notre
responsabilité
en tout cas de nous de nos dirigeants
chose que je crains si vous voulez avec
ce débat sur tout ce qui est six verres
c'est que comme pour le renseignement
soit toujours à se demander si on peut
pas améliorer les renseignements mais
n'y aurait l'analyse améliorer la
collecte alors améliorer la lutte contre
la haine en ligne parce que tout ça ce
sont des sujets intellectuelle si vous
voulez qui nous vont bien qu'on en
pratique assez facilement en france mais
maintenant on a besoin d'action si vous
leur bien sûr si on peut lutter contre
la haine en ligne la diffusion on sait
que le internet a été un support
important sur la radicalisation ouloto
radicalisation où la houle inflammation
d'un certain nombre d'individus qui sont
passés à l'acte donc on peut pas dire
que ce soit quand même sujet mais encore
une fois faut pas que ça devienne un
refuge intellectuelle pour ne rien faire
sur le plan d'action maintenant ce qu'il
faut c'est passer à l'action et je crois
que les français sont ils sont attentifs
et pas que les français mais les
européens en général ils sont attentifs
et il ne s'en tirant pas encore une fois
avec une pirouette ou avec un débat
intellectuel non plus finir
merci beaucoup gilles sacaze anciens à
cadre du service action de la dgse
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
front